I can remember the first day I ever
stepped foot into a video game arcade
and I remember the game it was space
invaders but yeah I've been addicted to
video games since I was a child and at
that time I never could have imagined
that video games would one day
incorporate acting and being asked to do
my first video game with Shinji Mikami
is like being asked to do your first
movie with with Martin Scorsese are you
injured what happened here
doc doc what the hell is going on I
can't help if you leave me in the dark
doc and you need me to help my favorite
part of working on the game I have to
say was seeing playback of the actors in
Japan who had been doing the motion
capture and they're dressed in these
ridiculously tight suits to go throw all
these imaginary processes at the end
they're just in this studio it was fun
it was really fun to see other actors
put in the majority of the the energy
Oh trying to make me feel sorry for you
I'm a fan of video games I always wanted
to take part in the process to see what
it's all about and I'm really excited by
it I want to do more Kidman is she here
too is she all right she's hardcore and
all about the business and the work and
efficiency and and smart but not a nerdy
way you attacked me I'm sorry but you're
tainted now I don't know that I had a
favorite line but it was a list of of
like you're being burned there's acid
being poured on you you have an itchy
brain would all of those things were
being thrown my way it was named you
laughs hell yes I want to do this work
again this is fun I like the action
stuff I want to do the motion capture
subject feels as I do but this vessel is
far too weak to withstand the
psychological way down myself bear Daly
you know I've never really thought about
doing voiceover work in video games it's
real fun there can be no mistake this
one is compatible you know I kind of
find that you know when you approach a
character it doesn't really matter
whether he's an evil character or a good
guy the actual kind of preparation and
you know the process is very similar
you were never out of my mind the way
video games has changed since the 70s is
like incredible I remember pong you know
I love that game the change in video
games from might say in like the 90s
till now has just been insane
you